what was the worst
experience you had with drugs man where
maybe like you were like damn
like this [ __ ] really i gotta reconsider
what the [ __ ] i got going on over here
um i had a bad situation happen to me
a couple times but the one that always
comes to mind is
i was in new york you know i was like
uh going through a breakup at the time
you know [ __ ] was just just felt you
know for me
a lot of times when i get in them dark
spaces i just feel like the world is all
against me everybody's against me
everything else
you know what i mean yeah so i just sat
in my hotel room
i answered the phone and i just got high
bro
like whatever i could get my hands on i
was just like just trying to escape
whatever my reality was at that time
then i woke up
uh on a bathroom floor yeah
wow and like oh all right here was
bruised i guess i have fallen fell on
your face probably yeah i mean
[ __ ] and that was like that was like the
awakening for me
that's the beginning of the end i didn't
i didn't quit there
i didn't because i was you know still
messed up you know what i mean but yeah
man so it's also a lot if you're on that
[ __ ] regularly
people don't understand how hard it is
you just like to quit cold turkey off
some of that [ __ ] is not
healthy yeah to be honest you know
but i'm glad man i grew a lot i think um
i'm the type person i got to experience
things i gotta like you could tell me a
thousand times
what something might do the stove is hot
the stove is hot yeah you gonna fight
you gotta break your hair
all right cool yeah you're right you
know like that's how i am so
you know it was a blessing in disguise
it really showed me everything that i
never want to be um
that's some real [ __ ] i think i think
too like like you said like we
we i mean especially you and i probably
similar in age
we kind of came up in a different era of
socially when it came to
some of those drugs and i think it
became so like
it's so accepted to get into certain
drugs that if it was the 90s people
would like clown you for
and like you said like you know you you
go through
a situation like that it really makes
you look at yourself and be like damn i
i if if i was looking at me from another
person's body
look at this [ __ ] guy like that's
really what it is and honestly that's
see i approach life like outwardly like
that because
you know people be like oh yo don't you
know don't don't get around this person
or
this this guy's a bat and i'm like yo
you could learn what not to be from
somebody
and it could be equally as important as
learning what to be from somebody else
you know what i mean
and i had to learn what i didn't want to
[ __ ] be you know that was
that was that moment and looking and
being like yo the same
i don't like this for myself you know